[Music]
all right
ah
what up is there what up everybody
hey boy Travis is back
another Banger on the way
another bigger stream on the way podcast
whatever you want to call it we're back
at it with 12 talks with your boy your
host your guests your everything
yeah
we had a good weekend man I had a great
weekend
really good weekend welcome back to the
stream let's get into it
what's up everybody give me a word long
before this but he's been holding it
because it's not about them
this is about us
this has nothing to do with the team
that's opposing us this is about us this
ain't got nothing to do with the
naysales the the unbelievers the haters
the doubters
this is about us when we started this
journey we told you it was going to be
trying it was going to be tough but you
wouldn't do it
because it's about us that man next to
you is a miracle that man next to you is
a believer that man next to you is a
go-getter that man next to you is a dog
that man next to you somebody who won't
this day that man next to you somebody
who believes that man next to you
somebody that gots to have it today
we ain't coming no more
[Music]
[Applause]
give me my theme music
[Music]
all right
but yeah it's close prom
hey don't we do best give us the best
free game speech we can ask for
hey that right there fired the boys up
it was time to go at this point right
before the game
all the Jitters and everything that we
had
going out the back though it's time to
go out thereby it's time to go out there
show time at this point so yeah great
pre pregame speech by coach Kron
he can always give us one of those he
always come through one of those
best motivation in the speech speeches
that we always get oh right here we do
this before every game
with this last year it's a tradition by
now which is always good me and Coach
Brown Embrace each other before every
game give me a couple words tell them I
love them let's go
uh
it's time go out there and show them why
you're one of the best to do it
one of the best
and I told him yes sir I got you I love
you
you tell me I love you let's go Sean and
that's what I did when I did put in the
work
all day long fall Camp practices and
stuff
came into play all right what y'all got
to say in the chat
hopefully this week good game I'm a
husky fan but you are a generation
Talent yeah thank you hope this week is
a good game too last week was a great
game for us
we got a lot of things to clean up but
hopefully you can clean that up and go
to next week and put that game right
there behind us
how do I feel about playing both sides
of the ball
hey man I've been doing this for my
whole life
I mean I've been doing it I've been
playing football since I was four me and
my cousins my brothers there's always
been going at it always competition
nobody want to be off the field you have
to feel me you're not good so I'm always
trying to be on the field let everybody
know that I'm here I could be
ineffective in both ways no matter what
I'm doing but yeah
yeah this right here just
I don't think it was not a touchdown I
think it was a touchdown me I didn't
have control with my footstep got a
bounce but I started regained like me
put my foot back in bounce
I called it that's when I had control
but
hey we still score we still got touched
on it doesn't matter I go out there do
my best next time give me a touchdown
trying to do what I do best man God
didn't be a playmaker
here very good player nice nice guy I
mean remember the silver just before we
even went out there was talking about
let's go let's work
you'll see me I'm jogging in the middle
of the field like I hope you don't break
then he broke so it's time to go get him
yeah a couple plays later
that I did best the ball Hulk
that's what I do just a ball hog man
that ball in the air is mine I don't
care who watching
who thinks theirs I'm gonna take it no
matter what
that ball is mines
it's just a great pick right here I mean
this wasn't the coverage but I seen an
Open Door seeing the quarterback I
stayed locked on on them so I
do I do best play baited the quarterback
to throw me to pick
oh yeah that's right this way see look
you can see me at the bottom of the
screen jogging okay bro all right let's
go get them can't score because if you
score that's not gonna be good
so yeah do what I did best when you go
get them attack them got them down they
throw the ball a couple more yards got
to the goal line then I picked it off as
you can see then after I picked it off
I just seen this clip but right after
the game I've seen this clip
it was talking trash I mean they're
talking before the game I mean that's
what student sessions does they thought
we was just coming out there playing
around they thought this is the old
Colorado team but the deal we did best
man did what we got coached to do when I
didn't play football the best I've been
in it the best of the coaches try that
so
that's it for me the fans don't get to
me I mean
they just finished with a team that's
what they're supposed to be doing
but I think I understand now but yeah I
thought I picked man coach we got in
each other's face I mean I told them
that's why he told me what he uh said
before halftime well at halftime when he
was going into halftime he had a little
interview on the field he told me he
told him
if I catch them two touchdowns the
housing is at the house waiting on me so
I told him I got you I came back out
I think I was the last person I was just
me and him who was talking and then I
said I got you next thing you know it
happened that same recorder came out did
what I do best picked the ball off got
in the face and tell them that's why and
I guess just kept sending it he said
and that's that was a little moment
right there let's talking to each other
I mean it's great to have a coach that
got a great sense of humor and not
always trying to be sitting there tough
yeah I'm so excited to watch you over
the next few years appreciate it man
just I don't do best
I'm blessed to do what I do stay healthy
I will
just gotta continue to get treatment
like I do all day long all the time
how is playing for someone like coach
prom I mean it's
I won't say I haven't played with nobody
else other than coach from in college I
mean High School
my coach was good but me learning from
somebody that got to go jacket is
special I mean you teach me all the ins
and outs that that play right there
like unless you knows like
he taught me he taught me that
I just had the instance to go get the
ball take the ball away I mean he told
me alignment I seen the receiver close
alignment ain't nothing else coming back
that way unless they run into mesh but
they didn't run the mesh my dude ran
inside picked that picked the line back
and tried to get the running back out
but coach farmer already taught me that
he told me that months ago it's just
something that I replayed in my head in
the middle of the game my receiver tight
he's either going under or he's running
out route he took an inside release so I
know he's going under watch the back
come out later the quarterback picked
the ball off so this is a special plan
for him he teaches a lot you just gotta
take it in and learn I'm very good
learning I sit down learn
house goes Lewis because Louis amen
great coach
he he doubted up that game I mean all we
did was believe in him and
he showed us why we need to believe in
him and
we deal with exactly what he taught us
all right
I told y'all
last week
the door is good
y'all he's that guy nobody want to
believe me everybody thought I was a
fool for feeling number two in the
Osmond list that I had hey I told you
just went out there for 5 10.
only knock incompletions
you know why you're not incompletions
because us not him us receivers we gonna
fix that up no drop balls we gotta make
our quarterback
hey 100 we get them to 100 ain't nobody
stopping them you gonna be on the top of
the house in the list nobody there
waiting that he's just got to continue
to have that game continue to have those
games
continue to have that Poise spin it
staying in our pocket and trusting his
receivers I mean he's done that he
showed y'all he could do it on any level
I mean everybody that was down with him
the guy stopped down no bad my boys
really like that he's really gonna sling
that ball around that's what he does
510 yards you can't explain that it's
nothing to say on a very good team
there's nothing you can say about that
510 yards is Crazy 80 I think 81 percent
something like that 81 percent
talking about hot tub on the plane with
no hot tub on the plane
now that was funny though I mean if I
had a hot tub on the plane
got needed that the game but uh I was
good
I mean when I got back to the school
after the plane I got straighten the
coach up
coach up taking my legs back refresh did
some more treatment today yesterday just
continue to do treatment on my body keep
my body healthy man I got a long season
ahead of me
I mean but I did that game that's what I
got to do every game so I just continue
to get treatment I mean because I'm not
lying I did play a lot of snaps yeah
Travis on the play 129 snaps as a
two-way player for Colorado today Steven
corner and 100 degree plus Heat
hey
I had 11 catches for 119.
one deception could have been two
interceptions
[Music]
because I had two touchdowns that's my
fault though nobody else fault I mean I
just gotta go back I got things to work
on I have one pbu
I wasn't supposed to be a pbu should
have been uh
should have been an interception but
yeah
[Music]
that's one of the most insane secret
game performances and any
performances any player has has done in
the ocean
bro I mean I've been doing this my whole
life man it's nothing new to me
I'm just very humble thank God every day
for blessing me with the talent I got
it's God doesn't work hard I mean if you
guys didn't work hard you'll see the
results everybody else to see them too
so I just got done work hard man 129
snaps by far the most snaps I played in
the game I mean high school games not
even that long so I'm not gonna play
that many high school I played I think
High School game but
it wasn't hot it wasn't that hot
but I kind of got my win back I kind of
got my win again
at halftime so when I came on halftimes
it's like his first quarter again so I
was trying to keep it continue to go as
y'all touch nothing fix me that's my
fault
yeah TCU coach
Sunny Dykes talk about me playing the
whole game like I played it was my first
quarter in the heat that I did in there
I mean I've been doing this my whole
life I just treat my body right
don't smoke bro drink don't do no drugs
drink a lot of water I drunk a lot of
people like
Gatorade
eat
man just got my buddy
just treating my body right so I could
be able to do what I've done
so
that's pretty much it I mean you're not
lying I went out there
lay my butt off every play that I was on
the field
you see you before
I was in the defense for Colorado nah
Jimmy Butler was tied me I wasn't tired
I was ready to go I could have played a
whole nother game the same day the next
hour
I was just ready to continue to ready to
play I mean I love football man
this thing I do the most
I love it I want to change anything for
it
I just love going out there and playing
I mean I would have thought after the
game I could have went out there and
played again I know y'all see me but my
little dancing dance in the locker room
you're going on that TV 12 diet nah I
pretty much eat whatever I want
yeah see me look after the game
like I got first legs again ready to
guard them play again doing my little
dancey dance
but yeah I was having fun man I have fun
with my teammates we had a great time
out there in Texas
Dez Bryant tweet not a lot
you typed it a lot but he's basically
saying
there he if he was a coach he would put
in a certain package for me to be able
to play a certain
at certain positions he won't let me
play full game like I did
he said he'll make me a full-time DB
which my coach prom said today I would
be bored like I just can't play
full-time DB so I lock up one side of
the field I get like I have five targets
I think this game
and then
I'm only on certain plays in the offense
that's not good enough for me I mean I
want to play the whole time
the whole game
as many places I can get in that's how
many players I want to get in
yeah that's my tweet they got hey I see
somebody say we got the worst roster in
college football he said we have the
worst roster
so I watched it was worse than UMass I
don't know what UMass got but uh
we're just trying I I was tweeted that
to be funny I mean we just showed them
so now don't try to hop on the bandwagon
I hope y'all believe like coach prom
said
what's my favorite game Day meal uh I
eat a Chick-fil-A biscuit and drink a
cookies and cream milkshake
that's my game day breakfast right there
that's my meal tacos or pizza
tacos
was it fun setting up those TCU fans at
the sideline I mean I know they mean on
the side line but yeah yeah it was fun I
mean when when people don't have a
rebuttals I can't say anything back it's
fun you just look at the Facebook
no I should never said that there's
nothing else for them to say so yeah it
was fun
hey go out there and just play continue
to grind do what you do best believe in
yourself even when people don't believe
in you don't let anybody doubt you just
I don't work at the end play
[Music]
stay there
wow
prime time give
me
yeah
it's funny that's my first time seeing
that clip I mean yeah we got a lot of
dogs on our team like he said
we are coming we ain't coming tomorrow
we here awesome but yeah
for Heisman yes I'm voting if I had a
vote I vote for him
Prime centers Hunter centers Edwards
we got a team to root for D Wade d-way
she could be waiting
uh these are all the celebrity tweets
the way twos about us yes sir
definitely got a team to root for
what's the petition for this weekend I
don't have a prediction I just got to
play Kevin Garnett the Travis on the
kiss is all 99s
yeah man I hope I am I'm just gonna I
just gotta continue to work I got a lot
of work still put in 119 yards ain't
good for me one interception not good
it's not
good but that's basic I mean outstanding
numbers to get where I want to be to do
what I want to do
appreciate it Kevin Garnett
General Ramsey absolutely special what
we're witnessing with the these boys uh
Colorado and that's something I never
thought I'd be saying to be honest
we got hey
I told y'all man
we got a good team we're not all about
the talk
we're just ready to go out there and
play and that's what we do
I tell my son CD guys
[Music]
son Jackson Jarvis Hunter security
himself a bag and it's only the first
week got 11. hey
nobody didn't text me yet
appreciate it son Jackson
what's my favorite song to get me going
uh
I don't have a favorite son to get me
going
I don't even remember listening to music
that's the crazy part but I was
listening to music at the game I just go
out there and just I'm just so locked in
I'd be ready to just go out there and
work
keep up the good work appreciate it man
I will just gotta continue to be focused
focus is the main key
Dion centers believe Coach Brown
believes I should be the number one
number one pick and address offensive
defense
doesn't matter and I should play both
ways of both sides of the ball in the
NFL hey my coach believe in me I believe
in my coach everything that he teaches
me go out there and try to execute it to
the best that I can best of my abilities
I mean he thinks I should go number one
I think I should go no more I pray about
it every night hey it's always in my
prayer it's in God's hands
because Palm doesn't use the team
captain
and Coach jerseys are the leaders at DMV
and childish our dogs those four were
out for the coin toss yeah me and Jace
cavade uh
shadora and Shane got a l their leaders
men Chase feed me dog
ain't a dog
never better deal
I can't
I can't name one
I mean we got more than just me and
daughter Xavier Weaver like I told y'all
Jimmy horn Javon Antonio y'all didn't
get to see Javon Antonio yet
but wait till he Papa
dealing how it works
defense defensive backs hey we got a lot
of players that the world haven't seen
yet but
they will be showing themselves really
really soon
Kayla Williams on the same thing there's
going to be a movie yes it will be
it's gonna be a movie
we're not going that far ahead
next game is Nebraska focus on Nebraska
practice tomorrow
focus on them and yes I am scatter
Ralphie I don't like to be next to big
animals
I got a dog two cats and I like to fish
the team getting better I will
my son wants to know what other sports
you like other sports that I like plays
basketball a lot of play basketball
Hooper
I'm like Curry out there and I'm
left-handed
in the first guys watching Travel Center
Friday is one of my favorite movies so
yeah that's how they was
nonsense
I can't wait to see some other the
younger guys make plays some of the
other things make please
yeah we got them they coming trust me
they're gonna make plays in due time I
do you practice for receiving a corner
hey it's about doing practice
my coaches
what's your favorite color asking for a
friend
what is my favorite color
nice my favorite color is uh turquoise
and
yeah fly fishing in Colorado is insane
you got to get into it yeah a lot of
people keep telling me I need to get
into it
I will get into it soon when I get time
after the season What type of game you
got on the court I mean you go look at
my YouTube channel I got a lot of videos
up I can shoot I can dunk play defense
hey whatever you need I got it
all right now it's time for the pick six
these are my top
teams that I think
pick six is basically my top six teams
and at number six I got Michigan
that's my first team number five
should be Florida State
Florida State just put well not put beat
the brakes not beat the brakes but just
be LSU
that was a good game I was just sitting
down watching it yesterday it was a good
game number four
Ohio State
great team got a great receiver
and he got a good defense
number three
Bama
quarterback is special
they got a good quarterback
defense
good defense all around the team that's
a good team number two Georgia
I don't know how they do it but they've
been doing it for a couple years now but
I think what two in one last two
three they've been going crazy
and number one
Colorado
you still got a lot to prove but I got
us at the top I mean if we didn't do
anything
for real for real you just that was one
game you gotta continue and consistently
do that every week weekend and week out
so yeah that's my top six that's my pick
six
so yeah
hey that's my opinion Don't Judge Me by
my opinion
now
it's time for my segment name
so yeah
this segment is a blur you know what a
blur is being top and top because I know
somebody here yeah if I do it
but yeah first is me I was in the slot
down here in the bottle going deep the
door put the ball on me
and I went up and caught it and that's
what you call a blur head top on
somebody head catching the ball that's
what you call a blue
yesterday I watched this yeah that's
what you call a blur all somebody had he
had talked though give me that
that's my ball not yours
that's all he just said threw the ball
up and said Tyler game up 14-14
that's what you're calling blur
oh yeah
[Music]
blue tow truck is crazy I told dragon
that route was crazy he just cooked them
up
and I think that was to go ahead or to
tie it with Nebraska but he's slant
um
I caught on a post corner from the
outside receiver
it's Post Corner hey that's a night
nasty route
it's crazy huh toe drag ah good field
awareness good catch
insane capture no glove what
bro what
obj 2.0 is that you there's no way he
just snagged that with one pan with no
gloves that's crazy that's what you call
a blue look at that Defender too far
away cannot get to that point in he
still got the foot down and caught it
with one hand that's crazy
that's crazy
however player I can't wait to see in
NFL
thank you
coach Tom hyped me up at halftime
but sorry about the fur
let's play ball
see this play I was talking about this
is what I was talking about that's what
he told me in the locker room this way
he took this is what he told them
hey and I told you in the locker room
okay my I talked to him came in my
locker room one thing on my mind and
that was the shoulder that he's not
lying so yeah
okay
and for the next segment it's how it's
been loading hey
my highest man list
this week
number four
Jordan Travis
is a great game even though you throw
interception still had a good game was
able to come out after that uh
interception and was to lead his team to
a w i mean that's a great quarterback
great numbers do what he did to get his
team to win
and number three Caleb Williams
hey do it every week man weekend and
week out he go out and pick up good
numbers
I mean it has been winning from last
year just doing what he do best playing
football the best his ability number two
number two
is two
hey I told y'all manage your door when I
got through 5 10 I told y'all last week
that boy good
and I'm standing on that he's good
now y'all see it with your own two eyes
just because he played at HBCU doesn't
mean nothing
when I damn sure y'all he could play on
any stage
that's what I'm talking about and number
one
me I'm betting on myself
but yeah
hey if I keep on doing keep doing what
I'm doing if I had them two catches like
I said
and the other interception that I drop
hey
would have been on my house waiting for
me but yeah
that that's what I'm saying man I'm I'm
number one on my list so number one is
me number two door number three is
killer whims number four is Jordan
Travis don't judge me for my Heisman
list
that's just my opinion you have your own
opinion yeah
any questions about me switching helmets
in the chat
why not switch helmets I mean
F7 I wasn't playing my best game I mean
I dropped the touchdown pass can't drop
down
you're talking about too many passes in
F7 so I'm like ah gotta be the helmet I
just do this in basketball you just take
off everything and switch up my helmet
right at halftime I took off I switched
my helmet to my speed Flex which is
fitted so I took that I took my S7 off
in my speed Flex because I see if let's
feel better and it's fitted so I fit my
hair better and I could see a lot more
with it all and I cut the tape off my
cleats something was holding me back I
didn't have a good game I dropped a
touchdown fast
uh someone saw me back so I had to
change helmets
Hunters Island baby
Justin fields or adjusting hurt I mean
Jalen hurts
Justin hurts Jalen hurts or Justin field
I don't know to be honest
say Jalen hurts he led his team to
adoptedy top Justin Fields is good too
really can't
I mean you can do it but that one
you might have the best drip in college
football dang I do yes sir
Justin feels as Jenna hurts let me know
Chad
if you want to say Justin fields
Chesterfields anybody else
just feels Jenna hurts nobody
bye bye-bye
okay
uh
okay well all right
uh last segment is me just talking about
the team we got a home opener versus
Nebraska coming to our field
I wouldn't want to be I wouldn't want to
lose yeah I'm not going for a loss I'm
going out there to play best game yet
week one this week one it's week two now
so it's time to God damn work man got to
go out there and play football at the
end of the day the game is anybody's
because score start off with zero zero
gotta go out there and play we gotta
play our game we can't play that game
can't fall into what they do we gotta
we gotta do what the coaches are telling
us to do to get us better to get us to
win I mean
Nebraska good football team they got a
good quarterback gotta go out there and
be ready to play we gotta go out there
and play Colorado football
gotta be the bus okay
to go out there and lay an egg we gotta
go there and play I mean that's pretty
much it looking forward to playing
Nebraska can't wait to play Nebraska
I'm always ready to play the next game
but we gotta go to practice gotta
practice clear I do good
whatever
we'll see y'all next Monday appreciate
everybody coming in staying tuned for
the podcast
order screen what you want to say
whatever you want to say this
appreciate you it's trap Center and I'm
out
Bang
[Music]